[Music]
welcome to I'd like to know our weekly
Bible question and answer program here
at Secrets unsealed andom TV my name is
CA Murray and I'm in the company of
Pastor Steven bour and Pastor David
Salazar and we are with you and you are
with us and that makes us very very
happy and very very pleased because this
is one of our favorite programs for a
number of reasons including the fact
that it gives us the opportunity to as
it were dialogue with you to find out
those things that are on your mind and
in your heart and then it gives us a
chance to go back to the word of God and
answer your questions from the word of
God as these questions come in each and
every week week literally each and every
day should you want to be part of this
experience we invite you to do so by
writing to us at
TVM tv.org that is TV susum as in Mary
tv.org and we will get to your questions
just as quickly as we can and we will
answer them as thoroughly as we can from
the word of God we make you that promise
Pastor bour if you would begin by asking
God's blessing on our outing today we
will launch right in to today's program
let's pray Father in heaven we come
before you with
humility because we realize that our
knowledge is so
limited first of all because we live in
a world of sin where our minds are
affected by sin but we come boldly
because we know that through the help of
your Holy Spirit we can answer these
questions so we ask that you will be
with us through the ministry of your
holy spirit amen that you will bless
those who are watching the program and
you will bless us to provide the answers
that will satisfy those who are watching
the program we thank you Father for the
privilege of prayer and for answering us
for we ask it in Jesus name amen amen
and amen our first question today comes
to us from
lindel and uh he's asking we don't get a
location but he's asking uh a couple of
questions one why did God enact the
death penalty for breaking the Sabbath
in Exodus 352 so we perhaps we ought to
turn to Exodus
352 and what has changed for it not to
be enforced today so let's go to Exodus
chapter 35 and verse two Pastor Salazar
you do have that I have that and it says
there six days shall work be done but on
the seventh day there shall be to you a
holy day a Sabbath of rest to the Lord
whosoever doeth work therein shall be
put to
death so that verse really portrays the
the death penalty if you will for
breaking the Sabbath so the question is
why did God enact that death penalty if
you will for breaking the Sabbath uh we
know that actually this is um before the
law of God was even given the ten
command the Ten Commandments given
Exodus 20 the Lord already explained and
gave them uh the the Commandment or the
REM remind them that they need to
worship on him on the seventh day
Sabbath and one of the individuals tried
to uh and he used them actually he used
the Mana that he was being given to the
in the desert to remind them that they
were to collect the Mana for six days
and keep the seven day Sabbath free from
going out and work and they found
someone there that broke this the law or
and decided to go and and and you know
and gathered sticks to burn and whatnot
and and and and that's why the Lord
asked them to kill that individual
because he broke the Sabbath
deliberately he did not believe in the
word of God he did not respect the the
law of the Lord and so when that
happened we see now in this chapter 35
that the Lord tells them again or
reminds them that if they were to work
or make a labor in the Sabbath day in
the seven day Sabbath they were to be
put to death now why did God do that uh
they were under a Theo theocracy in that
time the Lord directed the decisions in
the not only in the religious aspect on
this aspect of their practice to the
Lord but also in their civil ways in
their Civil Life and for the Lord at
that time it was necessary for them to
have that you know death penalty for the
breaking the Sabbath this is again under
a the the theocracy
situation that changed obviously as they
departed from the Lord and they changed
the system or they kind of left the
theocracy and came to a god-given
monarchy level I guess God through the
king and the King to the people but even
then that changed some of these practic
that no longer were were binding I
suppose so uh I would say that is only
God who knew best at that time why he
established that we don't have a real
answer I mean at least I don't have an
answer to why the Lord specifically said
let put it to death but it's his
decision in that moment I want to talk
something out that occurred to me I'm
studying this out because and in Reading
um some of Ellen White's writings this
is something that's going to give me a
little homework but I I found something
that I need to research a little bit
better but let me just put it out for
your thought
um what triggered this was the word uh
Gathering or gilgal Gil
gal in Exodus
32 there is a gathering and in Exodus 35
there is a second
Gathering The Exodus 32 Gathering is a
gathering of rebels where God is is is
is dealing with them after the golden
calf incident when Moses came down he
gathered them together and gave God's
punishment Ed don't white makes the
statement that for a time they were
really outside of the will of God they
did not have his protection and they're
outside of his will and that golden calf
incident actually the building
of the sanctuary it it held things back
that they couldn't uh build the
sanctuary this second Exodus 352
Gathering is sort of a reinstatement or
reaffirmation of of the Covenant and so
for this one time it seems like God was
very very firm with them very very
exacting with them about the things they
needed to do
particularly those who were going to
work on the sanctuary that there were
certain things that were not going to be
done on the Sabbath and he was he was
this almost seems like a very special
incident because God is they are coming
back into favor with the Lord and
reestablishing their Covenant with them
so he's he's very very direct now you've
you you you burned a golden calf you
know you worshiped a golden calf you
know all the things that happen with
that right right so now we're we're
starting from Ground Zero again so I'm
being very firm very exact in how I want
you to do these things because I'm
getting ready to have you build a formal
dwelling for me to be with you and I
need these things to be like like this
to be like this because of your your
apostasy um again it's something I'm
that just occurred to me in answering
these questions that's why I like this
this program because it gives us a
chance to search into some things that
that that may not have occurred to us
but Pastor boy do you have something
that you want to add to that well when
Exodus
35:2
says work uh shall be done mhm uh six
days but on the seventh day shall be a
holy day for you a Sabbath rest of the
Lord whoever does any work on it shall
be put to death then the very next verse
says you shall Kindle no fire throughout
your dwellings on the Sabbath day now uh
there isn't direct experience where an
individual picked up sticks to to uh you
know build a fire on the Sabbath and uh
it's in the chapter that speaks about
unintentional sin mhm and sin with a
high hand ah intentional sin I think
Exodus 35 and verse two is speaking
about individuals who maybe go out and
plow their field on the Sabbath knowing
full well that they shouldn't be doing
that um you know this experience that
you find in numbers 15 is very
interesting um
it says in verse 30 but the person who
does anything presumptuously yes whether
he is native born or a stranger that one
brings reproach on the Lord and he shall
be cut off from among the people because
he has despised the word of the Lord and
has broken his Commandment that person
shall be completely cut off his guilt
shall be upon him and then you have the
experience of this man who went out to
pick up sticks on the Sabbath to build
of
fire this guy is saying I know that God
said that I'm not supposed to pick up
sticks but I'm going to do it and let's
see what he
does and even Moses didn't know at this
point what to do he had to consult the
Lord yes and the Lord says he needs to
be put out of his misery
and that's not exactly what the Bible
says but anyway what would happen if
nothing had happened to him when he was
picking up sticks
the next Sabbath there will be all kinds
of people picking up sticks on the
Sabbath so God wanted to make a
statement of this just like when Aza
touched the ark yeah God wanted to make
a statement I'm serious about this uh
now the question is why doesn't God do
the same today because we live in a
different uh a different government
system you know if you killed somebody
for breaking the Sabbath today you'd end
up in prison yes sir so so because you
have you're not in a the Ry like you
were me mentioning right but you are in
a representative style of governance
then uh you cannot do what God directly
instructed Moses to do in this
particular case uh so um you know let
let me put it this way
um does a will a person who uh
presumptuously breaks the Sabbath today
is he going to be punished with eternal
death absolutely course so what
difference does it make whether it's now
or later yeah ultimately God will Ex
execute this person the person will
suffer the penalty so now it can't be
done MH but later it will you know a
person who committed adultery yeah in
the Old Testament was to be taken out in
stone according to the legislation of
most because they were living in a close
close Society a society where there was
a theocracy mhm and so
uh but the adulterer is the adulterer if
he doesn't repent is he going to end up
being punished at the End of the Age oh
yeah of course so God says you can pay
me now or you can pay me later pay me
now in the case of Israel uh or pay me
later after the after the Millennium if
the person hangs on to the
sin and you mentioned very clearly you
know why is not enforced today change of
society even the the the the Jewish
people could not could no longer apply
the law was at the time of Christ they
were in the Roman Empire so they could
not put Christ to death even though they
declared him to be worthy of death or in
the time when there was um you know they
brought the woman to be uh founding the
act of of being you know an adulterer
adulteress and she's you know guilty to
be the stoned and the Lord you know and
they wanted to Temp him so that if he
would have say yes she needs to be
stoned they will say oh look what he's
telling you know the government uh to go
the government of Rome so he they they
were trying to entrum him to to make a
mistake but you know he he you know he
allowed the children of Israel to be
under the domain of other societies or
other governments and when they are no
longer in the theocracy then then of
course it's we are to not apply these
principles but it's important that we
keep in mind that to the Lord the
sanctity of the Sabbath is has not
changed it's the same as it was before
you know we are not to deliberately
going to sin on the day of the Lord and
you brought up a very good point once
Israel wanted a king yeah that changed
and they insisted they wanted a king
changed right everything went downhill
yeah because when God was governing
things were kept in order but once they
said we want a king an intermediary
intermediary yeah uh things really went
downhill mhm very good point well said
Brethren well done well done we have
time to take one one more this is coming
from Tanzania uh this is
maias and
um um he of course he greets us the
question is is it out of harmony with
the Bible and the spirit of Prophecy for
a young man to marry a woman older than
himself for example one month I'm trying
to understand the age difference
particularly when the woman is slightly
older is something is this something
that should should be concerning
according to our teachings now
in the western mind this question seems
frivolous in Africa it is not uh it it
the age thing has a little more weight
uh there than than it does sometimes
here um so we we'll take this one and
then we'll take the other one uh my
answer is one word
no well let me put it this way my wife
is 11 months older than I am so if this
applies that I'm a transgressor you're a
transgressor yeah well my wife is a
little older than I am but the
difference is that my wife is 11 months
older but she looks a lot younger yeah
ditto same thing well you know it's it's
a good question like you mentioned in
certain cultures or certain countries is
very is looked upon as a not a good
thing to marry somebody that's older
even even is by a month or so and I
believe that the spirit prophecy is very
clear in the sense that uh the
suggestion when there's because some
people have t taken out of context where
she says about the age Gap to say
there's no way you can have somebody
that is so much older than you but I
believe that this isn't in regards to
situations where the individual is is is
clearly much much older you know you're
talking about 10 15 year Gap where it it
might not seem to be the best idea to
marry you know with with such a big
difference of age but in in this
particular case you know being a month a
year even a couple of years older or
younger I don't see that to be any in
any way uh you know directed not to do
it uh specifically about a woman either
is not there's nothing in the Bible ory
in regards to that being a problem so
yeah no I will say with you is there
nothing to be worried about okay the
second question sort of grows out of
this one uh in the book Evan's home uh
he States and white invis against teens
getting married stating that a youth uh
not out of his teens is a poor judge of
the fitness of a person as young as
himself to be the companion for life
this is aous on page 79 however I know
that Ellen herself got married when she
was 18 uh could you please help me
understand why she did not follow a
counsel that she later gave thank you in
advance for your assistance I look
forward to your insights on these
matters I actually thought she was 19 um
but the person she married was 25 he was
he was 6 years older than you so um uh I
don't know if this quite fits you is
right on the B B B borders of being 20
and he was well in his 20s so and and
then they and then she was she was you
know one of the things that they they
got married for is because they were
they were traveling together and
ministering together and they didn't
want to cause any backlash or any rumors
uh traveling together they had some
people traveling with them but that was
not always possible to have this
chaperone uh and they were going to get
married they they were in love and so
they pushed it forward a little bit but
um that was the necessity of the work
that they were called to do uh so I
think her council is still strong and
still stands well you know the way I see
it is that Ellen White was called when
she was in her teens
MH and um she needed someone who could
be her companion not only romantically
but a companion for the work that she
had to do yeah and there was no one who
fit better than James White uh because
he you know he was actually along with
Ellen White a founder of the church yes
we can't apply the same rule to all
teenagers right because some teenagers
are very
immature some teenagers even in their
early teens are very mature yes so Ellen
White is speaking about rule of thumb
yeah generally speaking teenagers are
happy go-lucky and you know they they
they're enjoying life uh and and so on
but in the case of Ellen White in the
time when she lived she was a very
serious young lady amen as you can tell
when she got her first Vision she was
willing to be to become the prophet of
the Lord so to the rule there will be
exceptions right it's not a iron rule
where nothing changes you have to take
into account the
circumstances uh of the specific
situation and you know another thing
that I I would like to uh maybe mention
is
that it's it's probably ADI you know
advisable mainly for the for the
especially younger men to wait you know
it's it's even known uh you know by PSY
psychologist today that uh women tend to
mature A Lot F faster or or they're more
mature more ready for a relationship
than than men you know usually and that
is just one of the things that I I
believe in preventing issue from
somebody to be you know be married only
because they're in the need to be with
someone instead of really choosing
because of character because of ministry
call or whatever you know it's best for
them to wait till they actually have
done something in their life I remember
the the advice that I got early Beyond
was you know make the decision for the
Lord then for what you're going to do in
your life you know educate yourself have
education then look for somebody that
can fit into that calling or that work
that you have and then move forward with
family but you know if you jump ahead if
you want to get married without knowing
what you're going to do for life you
find yourself in a very difficult
situation early on so it's there's also
wisdom in the sense of like wait till
you're you know ready to have a family
wait till you are matured what you have
learned what you know what you want to
do in life I mean how many teenagers
today don't know what they want to do
you know in their life I mean how can
they trust their own emotions to guide
them to the right person so it's it's
it's because of these elements of of
maturity as you mentioned Pastor you
know the growth that you have to wait
and is best to grow out of age now I've
met individuals who are very very mature
at at a earlier age but maybe one in 100
so it's not really
you know easy to find I've also seen
individuals who are 30 or 40 and they're
very immature very true true true age is
not the only thing that makes person
mature not and coming back to something
that you mentioned uh Pastor bore if you
look at Ellen White by the time she was
in her late teens she had gone through
so much she she mentioned herself I I
used to be a little vain um about my
looks and I really wanted to get an
education well that stone in the nose
erased all of that right so she had she
had grown through that experience you
know she she had grown through that and
then she asked the Lord you know once
the lord gave her the calling she said
Lord if I'm supp to go to world leaders
and tell these people about the Lord and
and and correct men and you know the
society back in the 1900s what's going
to keep me from getting in using our
language a big head and the Lord made a
covenant with her it's envirment
testimonies he said through suffering
you know if if this thing that you so
fear
comes upon you through suffering I will
keep you humble and if you look at the
the suffering that she went through her
life from a stone in the nose which was
rough but I mean she went through pulsy
and sickness and and all kinds of things
you know uh kind of thing but so she
made that Covenant with God if if ever I
get out of line I'll be brought back
through suffering so she was a very
unusual child uh a young person so by
the time she was uh in her late teens
she she was ready to to to to take a
spouse and she was ready to begin to
lead uh uh people who were being
fragmented by the 1844 movement of
course and things that came thereafter
so this is an unusual person and that
maybe why uh she didn't follow her
counsel because it was not for her it
was for those who were much less in
their Spiritual Development another
important Point CA is that uh she grew
up under the influence of the millerite
movement yes the greatest Revival
According to some since Apostolic times
and so she was very committed to the
Lord she called the year that that that
was leading up to the time when Christ
was supposed to come she says it was the
happiest year of my life yeah you know
that shows a level of maturity the fact
that she went to the meetings the fact
that she was excited about the message
uh it shows that every rule has an
exception or sometimes exceptions if you
don't believe that just look at the
English language
so so we cannot apply an iron rule MH to
every teenager and say Ellen White is
saying that no teenager should get
married uh in their
teens it's important to to to remind the
young people you know to follow the
council follow the council as much as I
mean as close as you can and if there is
a there is a reason for that Council to
apply in your life if you you are
yourself are you know like I said not
not knowing what you are to be doing
you're not sure what what type of school
you need to do or what type of work you
want to be you know it's the lot worse
things for you to that moment still
being you know a teenager trying to find
a partner for your life you're gonna
truly mess up the life of yourself and
the partner you're trying to seek and
and this is why you know the advice is
but today I don't know if it's happening
in Africa specifically in Tanzania but
you know today the the majority of teens
are no longer seeking to be married you
know they are trying to avoid marriage
at all you know they don't even think
about that at all and they are of course
uh that doesn't mean that they don't
break the laws of of of of of sexuality
and whatever you know that the Lord has
established only for marriage but they
are no longer taking marriage so I think
that you need to advise this you know
young man to uh to wait in the Lord if
he's young and uh if if the Lord will
provide him the right person will be at
the right time under the guidance of the
you know the the spirit of God and and
those that are near him his parents are
the leaders of the church amen yeah good
information and uh Good Counsel um for
your life it's it's it's tough to to
kind of put the reins on teens sometimes
when they when they get ahead of steam
but uh we hope that we pray and that
calmer Minds Prevail again our time has
fast slipped into eternity allow me in
closing again to wish you both Grace and
peace through our Lord and Jesus Christ
we'll see you again soon bye-bye and God
bless